oh
hello there i'm dave rubin it's 20
21 can you believe it people we made it
into the year
but i'm told everything's gonna be fine
last year
problematic 2020 big mess but now we're
in 2021
and everything's going to be a-okay it
is actually
january 4th 2021 and i am back
from 10 days in the free state of
florida so first off i hope you all had
a great christmas and new year i hope
you were around family and friends or
just people that you like i hope that
the ongoing lockdowns and general
political craziness and everything else
didn't destroy the end of your year you
know it's like
if there's ever a week to just kind of
let it all go
i sort of think it's the christmas to
new year break
all right i write about that in my book
like if you're ever gonna like take a
little time off
social media if you're ever just gonna
like focus on family and friends and
everything else that seems to be the
week to do it
that's definitely what i did i was down
in florida
with my sister and her husband and her
kids and it was actually the first time
since lockdown began believe it or not
so since march that i've seen anyone
on my side of the family hadn't see i
still haven't seen my folks actually
were working on that but i hadn't seen
my brother or my sister my nieces and
nephews and everything else
so i got to see my sister which was
great and and the kids and all that kind
of stuff and yes
i was in florida so we're gonna do a lot
of lockdown stuff today
and just sort of get everybody caught up
on everything going on in the world
but in florida this incredible
state of florida well let's throw to
some images here because i started
in florida in west palm beach i did
what was my first and last speaking gig
of 2020. if you would have ever told me
that i would have had
only one speaking gig in 2020 i would
have told you you were crazy i mean this
is after a couple years of where i've
done
that in some cases like in 2018 over 100
speaking gigs in a year with jordan
peterson but then in 2019
did probably 50 60 maybe even 70
speaking gigs
i love getting out there in front of
audiences so i went
to turning point uh to their student
action summit and as you can see there
were
thousands of people there actually they
did social distancing you had to take
your temperature as you went in people
some people made choices to wear masks
some people did not
everything went responsibly as far as i
know nobody got
uh coveted there i actually did have a
covet test by the way
i went to a new year's eve new year's
night party in miami where
it was at a house it was about 50 people
and they had everyone take over tests
i hadn't taken a covet test this entire
time a strange doctor
jammed a giant swab up my nose it was
extremely unpleasant
but i did not have covid so that was
nice but anyway so i started off in
florida
in west palm beach and the event was
just great it was great to be out there
and if you haven't seen it actually we
did post the entire
video of my talk i did about 25 minutes
just kind of recapping the year and
talking to these young students about
freedom and all that good stuff and then
we do a little q a and
and it was pretty great and then in west
palm beach
after i spoke uh it was incredible what
we did
and i think we've got some video
evidence to prove it i went to lunch
outdoors it was it was just incredible
look at that
look at that that is sausage and peppers
i had that at an
outdoor restaurant it was it was just
amazing can we get that sausage and
pepper up yeah
it was just absolutely delicious that
was with david and my producer michael
they
also had meals themselves a complete
stranger
came to our table asked us what we want
to eat
and then a few minutes later brought us
the food and then ex in exchange for
money
we left so i they brought us the food i
paid them
and then we left i then got a coffee
at another place and this type of thing
went on i bounced around florida for the
next
10 days we were on the west coast for
most of it which i really like the west
coast you know everyone thinks of
florida as sort of fort lauderdale miami
like east coast stuff i like
the west coast of florida it's a little
a little calmer a little slower there
but i went to restaurants and i had
drinks i had mojitos and i had
margaritas
and i stopped by resorts where there
were people on
on the beach and at the pool and some
you know they taught you know there were
signs you know be respectful of people
and social distance when you can and
everything else
and uh and as far as i know there were
no super spreader events
people made choices for themselves i ate
indoors and outdoors and at all the
places by the way
i saw people be very respectful of all
of
the regulations so like even in florida
which is totally open it is not locked
down
if you go into a restaurant the the
servers and the staff they're wearing
masks and that's fine and if you're
wandering around within the restaurant
you put on the mask i didn't see anyone
have a problem with it you may not want
to do it but i didn't see anyone have a
problem with it i didn't see any
fighting or anything like that but when
people were wandering around and on the
beach and on their bikes and everywhere
else
and and you know out there with the
gators and the birds and the
dolphins and all the other fun stuff
that i saw it was like you made the
choices for yourself and
and it was uh it was just great to be
down there
and i mention all of this because i am
back here in california
and although i did try to take some time
off the news in the last week and i
actually did a pretty decent
job of it california is in as you know
complete lockdown right now so the
restaurants aren't open you can't sit
outside
you know businesses are just closing
left and right and i saw these numbers
that i felt after being in florida
it's important to talk about because
there are some really staggering numbers
so in florida right now florida has a
total population of 21 million people
21 million people florida is open it is
completely open
as i said you can go about your business
there and then stores are making
decisions for themselves
and and basically anywhere that i went
like if you went to the to the grocery
store or if i went into a shop
they asked you to put the mask on you
went ahead and did it i went into a
bookstore
there's a bookstore somewhere in south
florida by the way i'm not even going to
tell where where i saw they had about
six copies of don't burn this book and i
signed all the copies so somebody
uh if you use some contextual clues i
posted the pictures on reubenreport.com
you can probably find those books
but again everyone was respectful of all
these things california i'm sorry
florida has a population of
21 million people
there are 21 000 deaths
from kovid in florida so again 21
million people it's a huge state hugely
popular state
it's by the way the second oldest state
we just had to check this i would have
sworn
that it was the oldest state apparently
maine is technically the oldest state
uh you know the average age is the
highest in america
so 21 million people 21 000 deaths okay
and they're completely open so now i'm
going to give you a little context here
for what's going on with the lockdowns
new york let's talk about new york new
york is the the state i was born the
state that i spent most of my life until
i moved
out here about seven and a half years
ago new york has
19 million people so they have two
million
less people than florida
and they're a younger population than
florida they have
38 000 deaths so in effect they have
basically
double the deaths that florida does
while new york has been in either full
lockdown or some version of a full
lockdown
for eight nine months at this point and
they basically have the same population
right we're talking 19 million new york
21 million florida so the question is do
the lockdowns work and i think the proof
is in the pudding and no one seems to be
able to show me anything that would
uh make that untrue right like if
if the lockdowns actually worked well
then we would see explosions in florida
with an older population
and everything else but you know getting
away from numbers for a minute since it
is the new year i thought
i could talk a little bit just about
sort of where we're headed in 2021
related to all of this because
what i realized in florida was it wasn't
just
you know the weather's nice i live in a
place here in california that the
weather's nice
and it wasn't just that places were open
it really wasn't although it was great
to go to bars and be served drinks and
actually talk to strangers like i really
went out of my way i'm pretty friendly
in general
but i really went out of my way when we
were at restaurants we were at bars we
were at the beach we were at the pool
wherever i went i talked to people and
people want to talk i think actually
what i could tell in florida is that
people wanted to talk more than usual
because there's a lot of vacationers
there and they want to oh my god
remember
remember a year ago when you used to
talk to a stranger he used to sit at a
bar hello how are you i'm fine how are
you what's going on okay
but what i really realized by being away
for 10 days and being
in florida is that there's a culture and
i think this is what we're going to
really realize
is is going to smack us in the face if
it hasn't smacked me in the face already
in in 2021 is that there is a culture of
fear and then there is basically a
culture of freedom
and it doesn't mean that you shouldn't
have any restrictions it doesn't mean
that this is a hoax or any of that stuff
it really doesn't i know i know two
personal people in my life
right now that that have cobit one is
one is young
about 20 and he's feeling a little under
the weather and he'll be better in a
couple days and then in case you haven't
heard it
uh my friend and mentor larry king has
cobid he's 87 years old larry has
survived something like seven heart
operations he's had cancer and a series
of other things
he's in the hospital right now i'm
praying for him and and i love him and i
hope
he as well so i'm not sitting here
telling you that that covid doesn't
exist because it obviously does
and your health and your behaviors and
age and all of those things
are all part of the the pieces that will
enable you to to kick it or not um
but but basically i sense what we're
going to see going forward is that half
the population
lives in sort of like a general state of
fear
and they want the machine to just kind
of tell them how to live
and then half the people want to sort of
be free
they live with the spirit of freedom
because the people that i met in florida
and there was one night where i was at a
place where there was some live music
and
it's a it's a local musician who i've
watched for years
uh since i was a kid and uh i and i said
hi to him
and he immediately knew who i well i see
on fox all the time blah blah blah
and then there were a bunch of it was
older people there were people probably
in their 60s or 70s sitting around and
everybody was talking and laughing and
having fun
and and i chatted with a lot of the
people and and apparently there's a lot
of fox viewers down in florida
so they all kind of recognize me from
that um
but but i sense it's just sort of how
you view the world
do you view the world in a very fearful
way and that the system can somehow
protect you from everything
or do you want to take a little risk and
i would connect that
i think to a little bit about belief and
about faith and what
what what allows you to to live with a
little risk
and and i also think that and i did
think this a lot when i when i was away
that we are going to have to also
realize that a certain amount
of people in the country are just
generally speaking are just
kind of brainwashed at this point and
it's also
not fully their fault right like if you
just
watch the mainstream stuff you're going
to be brainwashed to a degree
and then you're going to think oh the
government gave me 600
how wonderful that is while the
government also gave 10 million dollars
for gender studies programs in pakistan
and i'm not even going to get into that
whole
ridiculous spending bill which was
absolutely ridiculous and it's funny
uh it's like you know the government
okay they're giving us six that
six hundred dollars some people wanted
them to give us two thousand dollars how
about you just suspend taxes for
everybody how about you stop taking our
money in the first place
wouldn't that be nice that seems like it
would work for me but any event just
kind of
packaging all these things together uh
i've just realized that
the idea of federalism you know i talk
about it all the time in states rights
and you should live where your values
are
are more congruent and with people that
that are sort of in line with what you
believe
like we may be really seeing that
experiment play out in 2021 we know that
tons of people are leaving california
and it's funny is anyone i mean can
someone show me some numbers on this is
anyone leaving a red state right now
is anyone like i've had it with this
open state and these lower coveted
numbers
and all this freedom and my ability to
go to work and go to school i'm moving
to california
like nobody's doing it nobody's doing it
right so you don't need political
analysts and you don't need analysis
and everything else to show you that and
experts and scientists it's like
what makes us tick i think it's it's the
desire to be free and live life and
everything else and i think we're just
gonna have to accept that a certain
amount of people just can't
really understand that maybe that's a
function of of poor education it
probably is
and it's a function of a really
dishonest media that is just
absolutely awful and everything else um
but i know and one of my resolutions for
2021 is
i don't want to just be defined by all
the things that i'm against i mean i try
not to do that in general right i try to
tell you guys what i'm for and not just
rail against
all all the bad stuff and i think part
of that will just be
acknowledging that a lot of people are
just brainwashed by the system
it just is what it is and and it's our
job as i would say awake people as
opposed to woke people
to kind of show them hey you don't have
to
uh have this sort of fake blue pilled
existence you actually can
can fight for things yourself and
everything else and and one other thing
on the
on the culture of fear and all that and
then i'll move on is that as it was so
open in florida it was just and it was
just nice it was nice to see people's
faces
truly it was nice to see people smile
and talk to each other and everything
else
i got back to california and we went for
a hike yesterday
i was yelled at twice uh one now first
off we were outdoors it was four of us
it was me david and david's brother and
girlfriend we're taking a hike we're all
relatively young healthy people it's a
beautiful day in california
not a lot of people out there we're just
taking a hike and
and a woman passes us we didn't have
masks we didn't
right like and again we're outdoors okay
i know
we're supposed to cancel everything
thanks eric garcetti we were outdoors
and uh and a woman walked by and she was
in a mask and she started yelling at me
and i said man we're outside you know
we're outside so it's okay
and she said you're not reading the
papers and then i just kind of left it
there and i just thought it was a funny
thing to say like you're not reading the
papers like i got there like oh well
a times and i got the new york times and
i've got all of this brainwashing
propaganda and everything else
oh and then i got yelled at because a
bicyclist was writing like a maniac and
he screamed at me too
anyway the culture of sort of freedom or
fear or just like
having some sort of happiness versus
like endless misery and i think we're
gonna have to really realize
when you see all these videos of people
screaming at each other and everything
else that that this
is not how we're supposed to live we're
supposed to live freely
we're not supposed to have things on our
faces and everything else and i and
i i just sense that we can
we can't solve everybody's problems but
maybe we can show everybody that there's
a little bit of a better way
to do this in any event i will uh keep
thinking about florida
i had so many freaking people and i had
literally i had real estate agents
following me on twitter and finding me
on facebook and instagram
asking if they could represent me
because everyone wants me to move to
florida now i know a lot of people want
me to run
for california governor i'm still hoping
that rick grinnell might do that once we
recall
recall this [ __ ] gavin newsom
but i know a lot of people want me to
move to florida and on top of the fact
that my
in the midst of this we got our you know
my business manager sent us our
end of the year all our numbers and
taxes and everything else like when i
looked at the bananas numbers of taxes
that i'm paying here and i actually
although of course you know my feelings
on this i would prefer to pay less taxes
because i would prefer the government
to be less wasteful um you know there's
a certain part of me that's like oh but
if california is open and the weather is
good and all that and the people are out
and about and there's cool restaurants
and all that
then it's all good but if they leave you
with nothing if they leave you with
nothing
other than the walls that you live in to
be free well then it's like you look at
the number and you're like
oh that's an awful lot i could be saving
in florida
on top of you know more nice weather and
crocodiles and other fun stuff and just
nice people and everything else so we
shall see but i will say this i will go
on the record
on today january 4th 2020 the leading
candidate
if dave rubin is to leave california the
leading candidate as a state is florida
i know there's a push to get dave ruben
to tennessee right the tennessee people
want me
michael knowles wants me in tennessee i
know the daily wire people would love me
over there the blaze people of course my
my home people right love all the blaze
people truly love all the blaze people
glenn and tyler and everybody
well they would like me uh over in texas
but i gotta say there's something
about florida although it is humid and i
know that that would depress the height
of the hair
but right now that is uh that is the
leading contender
we shall see all right let's move on to
uh oh no so
we're gonna move on into some stories
actually but this is connected to
everything i just said here and
i'll do it kind of quick so one of the
things that i saw there's a guy on
twitter
by the name of at drew holden360. i've
come across him a couple times before i
think he's an interesting guy's got a
a good handle on what's going on with
the media and i saw this while i was in
florida i thought it was just perfect
he categorized and we'll throw up a
whole bunch of them right now tweets
that mainstream media has said about ron
desantis
who is the florida governor versus
andrew cuomo
who is the new york governor now i just
laid out the numbers right twice the
deaths
less of a population in new york all of
that
with the younger population yet the
glowing the
endlessly glowing media coverage from
msnbc
and from cnn and the new york times and
the washington post
and all of these slate.com and cnbc and
the rest of it
if you look at all of these i'm not
going to read all of them right now and
if you want to pause and you can you can
read them yourself
it's absolutely staggering and
staggeringly incredible when you see the
hypocrisy of the mainstream
media one guy ron desantis who i think
has
probably become the best governor in the
entire country
a guy just trying to keep his people at
work just trying to have people not have
their rights infringe on
while at the same time allowing
businesses to make choices
as i said earlier and you go into the
grocery stores there
and all of those things and even when
you get up from your table
at a restaurant they ask you to put your
mask on and i didn't see people
screaming at each other about it but the
way the media frames is that andrew
cuomo
is somehow a hero and ron desantis is
evil well we we give you about
this is that thread from drew and as you
can see there's just article after
article of
horrible media bias and these people
again guys this thing ain't going
anywhere
if you think that media bias is over
somehow
because maybe joe biden's going to be
president and obviously we're going to
talk more about
what's going on with trump in dc this
week and everything else i'll talk about
that later in the week
but if you think media bias is going
away it has just been ramped up to the
to the crazy point
and when i say earlier that we're gonna
have to accept that a certain amount of
people are brainwashed it's because of
stuff like that right
it's because they see new york times
headlines they see deadline headlines as
you're looking at right now they see
washington post headlines and they say
oh my god all of these bad things
about ron desantis and then all of these
good things about andrew cuomo and it's
like well you in a way you can't blame
them for being brainwashed because the
entire system is built
to brainwash people there was also
another great moment you may have seen
this a couple days ago of ron desantis
talking about
um talking about the the vaccinations
and he's like whoopty damn dude i'm the
governor i'm young i'm healthy like
let's get it to the people who need it
and it's just like that
i mean that that's a good governor i i
got to get the guy on the show we got to
talk to him obviously all right
uh let's move on a little bit because
because obviously you know i talk about
the california situation
a lot and i don't want to just focus on
california and i don't
i want to just focus on florida where i
was and i don't even want to just focus
on america because this stuff is
happening
all over the world i saw two videos
yesterday that were incredible and i
think that they're sort of
canaries in the coal mine for what could
really be coming to america
unless we really do wake up to this
stuff so this first video
is from twitter a twitter user by zol
nevery
on twitter and this is at an
anti-lockdown protest in london
and you're not going to believe this
guys there is a man a citizen in london
who tried to hug voluntarily
other human beings
[Applause]
yes human beings in contact with each
other we are not scared of kobe
come on
come on let's go let's go let's drop
these lying criminal politicians we are
not going to take this book
anymore come on who else wants to hug i
want to give me one
yeah that's it
take care i'm going to walk you out
clearly just been engaging with people
who are not in the same house
okay well i'm recording officer and i'm
i'm recording as well yeah you can
you can see the uh
going up to people do you know these
people oh you do know that human beings
human beings and government governments
as
inferior human beings okay
they are inferior to human beings okay
they are officers
officers of state that's a good man
right there
and i don't know who he is but i would
like to give him a virtual hug and if he
ever makes it to the u.s or next time
i'm in london if they let me in i would
like to hug the guy there's a great line
there he's
where the officer says do you know these
people and he says they're human beings
like me and the the fact that a state
government and law enforcement believe
that they can arrest or interrogate or
otherwise harass
decent citizens for hugging or shaking
hands or talking to each other
you know the phrase nazi is slightly
overused right i think we killed the
overuse of nazi
in 2020 but but this is the tactics of
nazism
making people afraid of each other
making people
afraid of the government and we
did i know a whole bunch of you joined
us for we did a v for vendetta movie
night
right before christmas and one of the
great lines
in v for vendetta is when v says people
should not be afraid of their government
government should be afraid of their
people
what right do these people have these
law enforcement officers other than
they're just
following orders which is by the way
what every nazi soldier
said after world war ii and during the
nuremberg trials and everything else
that's what they said
i was just following orders there was a
chain of command i was just following
waters
you can get good people to do lots of
bad stuff just by following orders
uh and one other thing and this is sort
of related to what i said earlier
that it's interesting when he talks
about god and government and government
is below god
and one of the things that i'm really
coming around to lately
i find it to be an inevitability in many
ways
is that most of the people that i sense
are brave right now
or clear-minded or willing to stand up
for what they believe in
it has something to do with belief and i
don't think that that's a coincidence
they don't believe that
what is true is just what's happening
right here this very second right like
they believe
believe that there's something true
above them and
i think that when you hear someone say
that it's like he's
empowered by belief and uh
it's a strange place for me to be
arguing from but it but it is something
that i've come to believe as well
uh let's let's jump over to canada
because i just showed you i just showed
you london
right uk let's jump over to canada this
is even more disturbing at some level
this is in quebec
where uh police bust into a house
because somebody knarked a neighbor
gnarked on this family for having
seven people in their homes
okay
[Music]
don't do that
yeah you should feel disturbed by that
okay these are police officers busting
into a private person's house
because they're having a seven person
house party i don't know how many people
lived in that house first how many
people they had over
or whatever it is they did but they
chose to have a house on their own
have a party on their own property in
their own home
and police officers are literally trying
to drag people
violently using force to drag people out
of that house
so if you look at that video from canada
and you look at the video
from london where amanda's trying to hug
people and then
you see what we're doing here in
california and in new york where we
don't let people go to work and then the
government oh here's your six hundred
dollars
here's your six hundred dollars take it
peasant uh i think you can see sort of a
broader picture of what's going on here
and that's why i wanted to cover all of
these stories on this first show back i
know i could immediately jump right back
into the sort of specific political
craziness and everything
that's going on with trump and this
georgia phone call and all of that stuff
and we'll get to that over the next
couple days but i thought that this
stuff was just
important because i think this is how
2021 is going to be framed we're going
to
keep seeing infringement on our rights
and it's not just going to
be wherever you live it's going to kind
of be worldwide and then
this will just get us to the to the
final thing that i wanted to talk about
today because
there was this video of ted wheeler now
as you guys know ted wheeler
is the mayor of portland this guy i mean
bill de blasio is
is the worst mayor in the country for
sure like this
he is an awful communist vile human
being who has destroyed the greatest
city
probably in the history of the world and
if you didn't see the video if you want
to watch some serious dystopian stuff
while normally we would have millions of
people in new york in times square
and i've done it on new year's eve many
times and it's actually pretty miserable
because there's so many people and you
can't get to subways and it's whatever
and it's crazy and all that stuff
so times square was basically like a
complete
uh empty just really dystopian sort of
scary nothingness on new year's
but but uh bill de blasio was dancing
with his wife if you didn't see the
video you should you should check that
out and then of course the other two
people
that were in times square were drunk
anderson cooper and drunk
uh andy cohen on cnn which nobody
watches and nobody cares
um but portland mayor ted wheeler who's
close behind de blasio right we got
garcetti's horrible there's a couple of
really bad mayors
bowser in dc is terrible and laurie
what's her name lori lightfoot
in chicago i mean she's just
but there's a bunch of terrible ones but
ted wheeler is probably the worst right
after de blasio just because portland
has become the epicenter of everything
that's happening with antifa
and we see just violence coming to our
cities and no one's doing anything about
it
this this is a clown who kept playing
ftse with them and not
using law enforcement to stop antifa
which in my estimation is a domestic
terrorist organization
he did nothing he literally had to move
out of his apartment because antifa was
attacking his apartment building
so instead of doing anything and pushing
back he decided that he didn't want his
neighbors to be harassed so he moved i
mean this guy's an abject clown
well finally over the last few days as
people have been throwing firebombs at
police officers and murdering down more
buildings and destroying every starbucks
which goes without saying
he's finally decided that maybe now
he'll do something
my good faith efforts at de-escalation
have been met with ongoing violence
and even scorn from radical antifa
and anarchists in response
it will be necessary to use additional
tools
and to push the limits of the tools we
already have
to bring the criminal destruction and
violence
to an end lawlessness
and anarchy come at great expense
and with great risk to the future of our
community
it's time to push back harder against
those who are set on destroying
our community and to take more risks
in fighting lawlessness in closing
once again i condemn anyone who engages
in violence or criminal destruction no
matter what
their ideology all right so look this
guy's just a clown and it's like
it's a little too late man you first off
you didn't use your tools in the first
place right you had you had officers
retreating constantly
we've seen the endless chaos no one in
their right mind would ever want to live
in portland at this point
and i hate to tell you ted wheeler but
the revolution is going to eat you
and you deserve it i mean that's really
just where it is
um so the reason i want to do that as
the fourth story is because i think
between
lockdowns between watching the
incompetence of our public officials and
everything else
i think that sort of encapsulates um
what 2021 is going to be about because
you know as i said before it's like a
lot of people are trying to show us oh
well you know 2021 will be the year
that we all come together we all you
know make amends and all of that stuff
and i just and i think that meme will
constantly be out there so that if you
say anything and stand up for anything
it'll make you look like the outsider
and you look like the bad guy and you
look like the
the guy that's going to spoil the party
and all that stuff and in fact if you're
one of those people who's standing up
for things and who's
fighting against the government that
gives us pennies while they take all our
money and that
don't defend us when they're supposed to
and that keep us trapped in our house
and all other things
you're probably the good guy you're
probably the good guy but because our
media is so terrible
it's going to be framed that you're the
bad guy and i promise you guys as my
first show
of the year that i will do my best to
continue to be a slight voice of reason
in the midst of that i'm completely
focused and ready to roll on that and i
know you guys are too
uh and i want to mention that you guys
should check out you can watch the
reuben report on blazetv.com where you
can get
we can get great shows by glenn beck and
everybody else you can join
us at reubenreport.com which by the way
it's a project of locals.com as you know
which is my tech company we're gonna
have some major announcements coming
we've got some really good stuff going
there and i just believe that small
communities are the future of the
internet i don't think
that big tech is and by the way that's
also where i respond to people because i
can't
respond to people on other social media
anymore it's just such a mess of
of awfulness so i can actually
individually respond to people on
reubenreport.com
uh as i said you can catch my turning
point usa
student action summit speech which we
just posted on youtube i believe
yesterday and oh and to end
this first edition of the reuben report
direct message in 2021
if you are a real estate broker in
florida and you're just sitting on a
piece of land you've got a gorgeous
house you're looking to move
email us support reubenreport.com
all right guys it's it's gonna be a
crazy year but i'm here for you
i'll be i'll be along the ride with you
let's see if we can make some sense of
it together
have a great day everybody we're back
tomorrow